avec nous ce soir michel leblanc pdg de
la chambre de commerce du montréal
métropolitain steve la voix pdg de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
québec bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir alors
beaucoup de nouveaux visages bruno
marchand catherine fournier stéphane
boyer notamment des jeunes des femmes
des conseillers un peu partout avec des
valeurs monsieur trudeau a dit
progressiste aujourd'hui on peut ajouter
écologistes quel message vous percevez
des choix des électeurs michel leblanc
d'abord ce soit ben clairement les
électeurs reconnaît ce qui est du bon
travail qui a été fait à plusieurs
égards
c'est clair que la volonté de la mairie
est d'améliorer la qualité de vie dans
les quartiers au plus à la population
aussi je dirais que l'économie de
montréal dans l'ensemble va très bien au
sortir de cette pandémie il reste certes
un enjeu on en paroles centre-ville
notamment mais dans l'ensemble
clairement la population à voter pour
une continuité il ya des nouveaux
visages oui mais dans le cas de montréal
c'est quand même la même équipe qui est
reporté au pouvoir c'est yves lavoie que
représente pour vous l'élection de bruno
marchand pour le milieu d'affaires de
québec
ça a été toute une surprise oui vous
l'avez constaté comme nous ils fière de
voir monsieur marchand mais il est clair
qu'un vent de changement
les idées à magny cours mais ça marche à
ce qu'on a entendu beaucoup de monsieur
marchand à toute la campagne est il
revenu le plus souvent le mot ses
collaborations collaboration à trouver
des solutions lequel mine d afin de
s'impliquer de pouvoir écouter et
trouver les meilleures solutions
alors on a bien de pouvoir s'asseoir
monsieur marché dans les prochaines
semaines pour pouvoir collaborer
justement à améliorer on parle de
mobilité lycée agri michel leblanc ya
quelques jours dans la presse valérie
plantes dit reconnaître qu'il y avait un
fossé entre elle et les gens d'affaires
de montréal qu'est ce que vous entendez
faire à partir de maintenant compte tenu
du résultat quand même très solide pour
madame madame me plante pour améliorer
le lien justement avec l'équipe et la
mairesse mais c'est clair que madame
planté - à travers les quatre dernières
années on s'est souvent parler l'enjeu
c'est parfois des politiques qui je
pense vise des bons résultats mais sont
pas toujours optimales pour le privé la
crise du logement vient à l'esprit de
tout le monde m'a même plante insiste
beaucoup sur la nécessité d'avoir du
logement abordable à montréal et je
pense que beaucoup de gens privés sont
tout à fait d'accord mais à la fin ça
prend plus de logements point pas juste
abordable mais pour tout le monde la
crise du logement c'est que les prix
montent très vite et les prix montent
très vite parce que pas assez d'offres
donc je pense le premier élément de
collaboration et c'est bon pour québec
mais c'est bon pour partout c'est
comment travailler avec le privé pour
qu'ils aient plus de ces projets oui
logements abordables mais tous logements
confondus
mais quand madame plan par exemple à
parler aujourd'hui d'un milliard de
dollars pour le centre ville le palais
des congrès la relance centre ville bien
sûr elle a parlé de l'est de montréal
leur m
est ce que tout cela coïncide avec vos
priorités à la chambre de commerce c'est
très aligner leur m2 liste je pense que
la mairesse vu que ça se réalise
évidemment sans fiasco centre ville le
développement des terrains de l'asse
prioritaires et et tout le monde le dit
je pense qu'un des enjeux c'est comment
trouver les bonnes façons de travailler
avec québec et je dirais que c'est
quelque chose peut-être où on peut
travailler tous ensemble le milieu des
affaires avec tous les gouvernements
l'amérique peut peut-être faire front
avec nous et obtenir des gains pour
montréal ça vaut aussi pour ottawa il ya
des responsabilités qui sont à ottawa
donc dans les faits c'est comment
travailler j'ajouterai rapidement du
point de vue de la cmm il faut
travailler ensemble et il ya des
nouveaux maires des nouveaux mais
nouvelle mairie et la mairesse pas des
records de ce point de vue là c'est
devenu une vétérante cessez donc celle
qui peut peut-être avoir un effet de
leadership sur l'ensemble du groupe et
faire en sorte qu'ils aient des bonnes
décisions pour la région métropolitaine
et pour montréal c'est yves lavoie bruno
marchand n'a pas voulu prendre position
sur le troisième bien et il a même dit
ce soir qu'il faut tenir compte des
évaluations environnementales
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ça
le troisième ligne est ici mon épaule
sur thriller et du tout la campagne
qu'ils voulaient pour se positionner hip
hop au pied pas compte non plus il veut
attendre de voir les études du côté de
la chambre de commerce on a sondé nos
gens d'affaires sont pour le troisième
ligne on n'est pas content des
améliorations si comme le réseau
structurant transports il veut amener
les améliorations on n'est pas content
de l'innovation ce qu'on demande c'est
de vous allonger les délais ça fait
quand même un certain temps que le
projet d'avancer de réseaux structurés
ainsi québec les gens hors de la voie
ont tissé des bleus alors
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
vous prenez de votre perspective un pas
de recul compte tenu des positions du
nouveau maire
on propose pas de recul dans le contexte
que l'on va s'asseoir avec le nouveau
vers la nouvelle équipe dans les
prochaines semaines dire quelle est leur
position soit effet revoir la combustion
de nommant les membres à la chambre de
commerce ici à québec des communautés
d'affaires appuyé le projet maintenant
on a un nouveau maire qui veut améliorer
le projet tenir compte d'études ça va
être respectée on va s'asseoir avec lui
mais la priorité bonjour aujourd'hui
c'est le réseau structurant transports
en commun qu'on attend depuis longtemps
vos amis repris la mobilité dans nos
parcs industriels pour ramener des gens
au québec alors c'est la priorité numéro
un est est ce que vous craignez que
c'est que le projet de tramway par
exemple soient ralentis parce que
monsieur marchand a proposé beaucoup de
modifications au projet de tramway
j'ai parlé à marcher marcher ce matin il
le dit toute la campagne croit au réseau
tout amour ils veulent améliorer alors
on re l'écouté on va voir les gens du
bureau j'avais quand même depuis
longtemps dessus nous ce qu'on demande
c'est pas avoir de retard et que la
facture nécessairement de grimpeurs qui
ferait des diminutions dans l'offre de
services alors on ne vient de ce soir
mais je marche je goûte vous demander
aux deux quelles sont vos priorités
économiques quand vous regardez vous
l'avez mentionné michel leblanc nouvelle
mairesse à longueuil nouveau maire à
laval il ya quand même une changement
dans la proche à partir de maintenant
les priorités économiques pour tous les
gens de la grande région de montréal si
je vous demandais d'en nommer deux trois
très importante pour vous d'abord
clairement la fluidité des transports il
faut que ce soit plus fluide sur l'île
de montréal au centre ville deuxièmement
la question des hommes d'innovation le
gouvernement du québec s'apprête à
désigner des endroits au québec où on
veut investir dans l'innovation il faut
que j'en ai à montréal donc il faut que
la mairesse monique ce commerce puis je
vous dirais un petit dossier mais qui a
suscité beaucoup de passion raymond
logistique clairement un projet privé
d'impôt de logistique à côté du port de
montréal la mairesse chambly gérer
évoluer dans une direction puis dans
l'autre ce projet là ça va être un bon
test très rapidement de la volonté de la
ville de montréal de faire en sorte
qu'ils aient du développement économique
bien fait mais du développement
économique néanmoins vos priorités
économiques steve la voie
clairement la pénurie mais d'investir
québec sud une problématique on est
revenu au taux de chômage devant la
pandémie c'est vraiment une grosse
problématique
on a tout l'aspect de mobilité qu'on a
parlé tout à l'heure et toute la relance
des secteurs ici à québec sont très
important de touristes la restauration
et l'hôtellerie et des secteurs en
croissance
il ya des secteurs qui ont vraiment
besoin de relance et comment montréal et
québec qu'on va terminer là dessus
steve la voie doivent collaborer
ensemble
or - michel on s'est rencontrés
justement dernièrement on a des enjeux
communs quand on se parle on se rend
compte qu on a des enjeux communs dans
chaque nouvelle respecte rsp et leurs
effectifs le chercher je cherche le mot
merci je sais qu'un bruit pendant
respectives merci alors je m'en
souvenais alors mais non des ponts de
communication qu'elle était montréal et
vraiment l'intention travailleurs envie
de collaborer ok on joue comme michel
leblanc moi je dirais rapidement ses
claques le transport collectif et est
une priorité partout et ça va prendre
des sous du point de vue du gouvernement
fédéral ou tank de québec donc des
coalitions comme celle là ça devient
très puissant et je dirais aussi
clairement la fiscalité des villes que
ce soit montréal québec une dépendance à
l'impôt foncier qui est tellement élevé
que ça facilite pas le travail des
villes donc on pourrait faire changer
cette situation là ok michel leblanc
merci beaucoup c'est yves lavoie
également merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir donc soit rien sur les tops pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit